[music]
Okay, well, good morning everyone.
starting a live stream on YouTube.  Let's
see if it's being
done correctly.  Permíodo.
Ah, yes, it
sounds perfect.  Uh-huh.  It sounds
perfect.  Okay,
let's see how the
market starts today.
Let's stop by here.  Let's put
this on.
Remember that those who are
on Discord can join.   I
will not be streaming on Discord.  Uh,
I'm going to do the broadcast directly
on YouTube.  Ready?  so they can go
and exchange their money directly there.
Okay, let's see, let's see the class.
Let's watch today's classic match.  Okay,
we're located in the SPX
of the S. Let's open the other
corresponding tabs.
Let's see how we started GETS
today.  Completely bullish, positive on
both.
in the
positives in both in the net gets
here too.  Let's see if I can
share it with you.
Let's take a look at what
our tool is.
There it is.
Well, positives for the gets side.   We're
also going to make sure everything is
properly positioned and that the transmission isn't being
displayed
correctly.
Okay, there we are.
And he'll also be posting the live
stream here so you can see his
comments on YouTube.  Ready.
Come on.
Well, so we're here
talking, we're positive within
the get.
Hey, remember that it's an imbalance tool
that inclines you towards both puts
and calls.  Ready?  Therefore,
at this time we are looking for
bullish entries
in the classic.  Let's go here in the
classic package.  Remember that
we have three packages: Classy State and
Order Flow.
Uh, we're here in the Classic package.
We see that
the zero range is also incorporated in an
upward trend.
We have the points, let's see here
we have the points here of the
profile, the profile,
quite positive.
We're on the 90-
day metric, right?  In the 90-day filter.   Let's
take a look at what's happening on the
stake package side.   Let's
see over here.  Ready.
state package.  And let
's go along the Delta side.  Delta
also has the entire profile,
extremely so on the upper side.
Let's go this way too.  We have the
highest volume and
concentration right near the
center where the price is located.
And over here we'll see what it is.   I'm
also adding another scene
that will allow us to
capture a window.  Wait a minute, let them
also see another tool that we
also have
, which was also developed for
integration.
There we are.  I think you can already
see it.
And I think I can change here.  Okay, that's
it.  Okay, I can change it here
, so
which one do we want to
watch?  Yes, there we are in our
Botmac integration tool.  Ready?  It's
exactly the same.  We can see what
the gamma is, right?  The range profile.
And here we have the profile of the delta.  This,
this is for those who have the
state package.  Note that we are
also working on integration, which
is the history, the history of the zero range.
Those who can see it, I'm going to
tell you what the history would be.   Wait a
minute, the history.  Let's go over here.  Here
we are.
Let's see what history is.
Ready.  Then we have the history, which
are the dotted lines.  We can
visualize it here.  Let's take a moment to
refresh.
Because of the transmission, I'll be able to
move around if I
can see quickly, without having so
many windows open.
I'll be testing the transmission
on this device,
but let's see if it works
properly.  Ready?  Otherwise,
I'd change teams by tomorrow.  Uh, the
history.  Okay, here we have the history,
which are these dotted lines, right?
Where the largest
positive and the largest negative are moving from,
right?  Look at these dotted lines.
When the market starts,
he shows me where
the highest positive profile and
the highest negative profile are located.  TRUE?
I can change this.  Let's go to
settings.  I can
change it here so that
we have that line as solid.
Let's go here too
so we can see it a little
better, right?  We saved the changes and
here we have it, right?  Right now
we're located right here at
6860 and here it's located at 681.
Uh, the range, notice that the range,
this spot cash price in the
correlation with the LS isn't touching
the zero line, right?  But they are
visible, if we visualize a little bit,
eh, yes, sir.  I don't have a screen on
Discord, I only have it here on
YouTube.
Hey, this way.  Let's see.
Hello, the screen.  Okay, I'm just
going to share one window,
I'm just going to share a single window of what's happening
here on Discord for those who can
also view it.
Hey, remember to check out our
YouTube channel.  We're also streaming on
YouTube.  Ready.
Um, let's continue with the explanation
here.  So, in Bootmap
we can visualize
that little zero line, how it works
as support as we saw in
the opening, right?  Here
we begin the opening.
Data from the zero range started arriving here, and notice
how it positions itself as a support point
for the entire upward trend,
right?
We see that we have
two lines here, right?  Which would be this blue one
and this little red one, right?  Those are the
maximum levels of opening interest.
Okay, we'll be able to see that over
here.   We'll be
able to see that, but it's already
on the web.  Here, open interest
is showing a higher positive value
at 70.01 and a higher negative value at
6660.
Bootmap allows us to
visualize this.  Ready.   We
're starting off on a completely bullish note.
Let's see how the delta is incorporated, let's
see how
we can look at what it is,
right?  We have a positive delta as a
point of support.  Let's see if it
displays better.  There it is.
Negative Delta.  Negative Delta as a
fulcrum.  That's how we see them starting to
come in, right?
to our first support point the delta of
this negative delta.
And on the Boomap side, we're going to look at the
Boomap side, we also have a line,
we're also looking at a
negative delta here too so you can see it
visualized, which is exactly
the same thing.
Okay, here I have this little one.  Here you can
see that the delta is negative.  We are
located here.  Here's a small
reaction.
Tools like
integrations allow us to see
a little more closely where
the price is reacting according to the
profiles we
have within our
integration tool,
right?
Uh, we see that it reacted precisely at
the largest negative of the negative delta,
right?  He reacted.  We are
also very close to the zero range.
And we have, let's see the profiles
too, I think we have all the
profiles and we also have what is
the net is positive.  Remember that
when we have a positive net result,
it's for those who were there
yesterday, for those who were
on the Discord stream yesterday,
we're going to put them, we're going to put it here to
change it again.
For those who had one on
Discord, we had talked about
when it correlates, right?  The two
nets of 0 DT, the 1T, this indicates to me
a greater price increase.
Yesterday we saw that one was
below and the other was above,
but since both are
above positive today,
right?
The purchase levels that
we have marked in the profiles
can be used to re-enter that
upward trend.   We're here
.   Okay, let's
continue explaining over here.  Uh,
we're already above
more or less.  This is an average that
one has, that you can also
calculate on a
daily basis, right?  As soon as it reaches
roughly that average.  That average when
the market starts.
We just saw a small
drop-off,
right?  A slight dip.
Let's watch
BMA so you can see how it reacts
here.
There it is.  Okay, there it is.  Notice
how
Bootmat reacts at this point
of zero, right?  Although now it's true.
Ready.  That's where the zero-gauge reacts.
We expect this range to influence us as
support, the first support for this
upward trend.  The break of the
zero range
could indicate a
relatively large bearish movement,
provided that our net GES is
also being linked in a
negative way.  I can practically put
, let's say, a point of purchase here.
Remember that our levels of our
small support level would be our
zero range, already seeing small purchases
within what we see in the
Boommap tool and placing ourselves,
let's say, as the different profiles.
Remember that we are... this is
all
in context, what we are seeing.
There is no investment advice, uh,
we are simply analyzing what we
are seeing directly from
our tools and the idea is to
gradually incorporate ourselves into the
different uses of these.
Ready?   Okay,
let's get started.  Let's move on
again to what we are going to look at
here. The net gets allows us to
look at the net gets at the moment. It is
relatively positive, that is, we
continue to bet that the
price will continue with its current trend
.
Let's go this way, I'm
ready.  Perfect.
I hope I'm switching between screens
correctly.
Since I keep changing, I
quickly switch between screens.
Ready.
Let's see.  Uh,
there we see that we are right
in the negative delta, right?
Uh,
let's see the gamma,
we have a negative gamma of 68.60.
Uh, we're located on the
positive latex at 6805.
Remember that we also have to keep
changing or visualizing the different
points.
We have the whole profile too, all
the profiles
directly positive, almost above average,
right?  almost above the price,
although it's a little stuck,
eh, in the middle,
but we are totally positive.
What is the delta?  Ah, well, what
the gets is,
this is relatively super important
in terms of continuity, in terms of
reaction for the 90-day one we have the one
for the current day and the next day,
right?
These reaction points, these points,
these negative
and positive reaction points also tend to influence
as support, okay?  As support or
resistance.
Always keep that in mind for
each of the
filters.
Well, you can ask me any questions
here.
Hey hey
, bootmap isn't visible.  Hey, people here on
Discord are telling me that the bootmap isn't visible.
Uh, you can switch to
YouTube to watch Bootmap.  Ready.   I'll
direct it a little more
towards the other channel, since I ca
n't broadcast both here on Discord.  I
cannot transmit both directly.  Okay, let's take a look at
Bootmap here in the transmission.
We're going to change the
Bootmap again here.  Then
they saw that our zero range
clearly works for us as a
support.  They can take it, although I'm taking
this entry here, because obviously
it's totally theoretical, right?  because
I'm explaining what we
're talking about in context.  Uh, but they can take
small entries, let's say, at this
point, around here, at
this point, let's say, as if to
take reference that at this
moment we are in a positive guess,
in a net positive GES, right?  And it
works for us as a support.  It works for us as a
support.   We would
already need to see a very
big movement to be able to make that break
of that net, that change in the
net gets along with the break of the
zero range.  Gama really tells us
where the market is headed, what its primary
direction is, right?
That's what it tells us.
Meanwhile, we saw that we
remain practically on standby
for the time being.  I'm looking at the
net side, which is that it has changed.
Something may have changed.
What I do like is that they visualize a
little how it reacts to the
different zones,
especially for the zero range.  It's
also super important that they see it,
right?
Okay, this has already been updated.
Let's update a little
more
here on the I'm currently on
the web.
Those who can't visualize, okay,
there's a "there, there,
uh,
there it broke," right?  That's where it broke
the zero-range standard on
the Boomar side.  They
can also take it as a reference to the fact that
they can throw away a point of sale,
right?  Protecting myself just
above the zero range.  Remember that this
is entirely theoretical; it is not
investment advice.
Uh, assuming it's a
break from the zero-gauge, right?   That's it
.
Okay, let's see, we're going to transmit from the
side of the bank.
Here it is.
We are here.   It's like it did
n't cool down.
There it is.
Please refresh this screen.   Let's
see.  He didn't want to cool down.   He stood
still.
We are experiencing
technical difficulties.
Maybe if you close a small window.
While we are showing what the
BMA is.  I think the BMA is taking a
large part of the burden.   A
large part of the load.   Uh-huh
.  A large part of the
transmission load.
So, uh, as you can see, uh, the
cellophane isn't currently
functioning as a small resistor,
right?  He will really start
reacting right after the
zero-gauge break as part of the
resistance.  We will see this
every day: when there is
a breakout from a
range, it functions as both
support and resistance.  Always keep
this in mind.
Uh, on the net side,
let's see that he finally showed me.
Let's put it here.  Ready.  Notice that
at the moment of the
breakout here, it's showing me
that the Nets' GU net price is making a
completely bearish breakout, right?
A completely bearish addition
below the zero line, right?
Okay, here we have it,
let's go a little bit here so we can see,
so we can see what it
is, although I can
hide it here.  There it is.
because I can hide it from him.  Ready.
So, what does the net gets really tell us? It's that we're
entering
an upward trend, and
we can always use
the zero point
of the net gets as a support or resistance reference?  Here we see that it is the
point located at zero, right?  It
works as support for the continued
upward trend, right?
We're up here right now.  Let's move on to the other
nets, which would be this one.  Notice that when it
breaks through zero here, it
also leads to the price
continuing downwards, and this would
also serve as a
resistance point.
Okay, so my screen went out.  There it
is,
there it is.
Okay, let's see if we can continue from here
.  Uh, both the profiles,
let's remember that we have two profiles here
that we can
see.  We have the first profile, which
is from the open interest group, right?  And the other
profile here we have the volume gets so
that you can take it into account
within our Classic package.
Okay, this way.
Well, they're asking me to share
on the Discord side of BooMap.  You can
go to our YouTube channel.
Ask here, let's see, they're
asking here on YouTube.  Hey,
will these classes be recorded?  Yes, these
classes will be recorded directly in
each live session we will do daily.  Ready?
Okay,
we're going to start all these classes
daily, for about
an hour, giving a little
context about the beginning of the market and
showing a little bit of our
tools.
Ready?
But I think everything sounds
perfect.
Okay, let's take another look at what's happening over here on the
pup map side so you can
see it a little bit.
There it is.  Here it is.  Perfect.  Very good.
Well, explaining again,
we had seen that the
zero-gauge break here, incorporation, here
we can see that incorporation of many,
many purchases, right?  Below
zero range.
Hey, remember that our
investment advice is not for you to take a
buy or sell position.  Uh, I
'm going in and out so you can
see the different entrances.  They have to
see, they have to mix this with
different tools that
allow you to visualize if
this break of the zero range is going to
be its bearish continuation, right?  I
'm simply explaining to you what a
readmission is, right?  In
our tool, the zero
range, right?  at least here.   We could have entered into a
purchase here.  Here we can also enter into a
purchase, here taken, let's say, a
breakout, a sale.  Here we
have also used "enter"
as a small purchase.
Um, whatever context you
place it in, with other tools too, let
's say, order flow,
footprint, bootmap,
different indicators that allow us
to visualize whether the breakout
of a range or the continuation
of the range corresponds to us, to whether we are
going to continue
heading towards our profits, right?
Uh, but I want you to visualize,
what I really want you to visualize is that
our zero range at the moment of the
break also works as
support.  Did you see?
Clearly, it was possible to see him
re-entering here again, right?  re-enter
purchase and we can take all, let's say,
all this movement
so that you can also visualize it.
Oh, and remember that I'm working on
a demo account, so keep that in mind as well
.
Okay, perfect, everything's OK here.
Uh, I like to see that they also
kind of interact a little bit
through the chat.  You
can ask me any questions you may have.  Ready.
Let's see.  Let's take a look
over here.  We're going to change the transmission.
Let's remove a little bit of Bomma.  Let's move on to the
web environment of our
tool.
Notice, notice that our
GETs are totally positive.  Totally
positive,
right?
And here it has already been incorporated, although a
slightly downbeat minute, right?  our
consistently positive.
Let's duplicate this tab to see if
we can visualize what the state is.   Let's
see what's happening in the state.
Hey, someone here on Discord is asking,
besides SP and NQ, is it
possible to see the Dow Jones?  No, you can't
see the Dow Jones.  Uh, what they
can do is a correlation that
we had talked about,
I think we had talked about it 8 days ago
, a few days ago last week we
had talked about that we can do a
correlation of the SPX, right?  And here
in the settings
we have a multiplier.
We had seen that we can perform
a calculation here.  Let's see.
I also
have it here.   Let's
see,
I think I have it around here.  Let me just a
moment.
Mm.  Yes, ready.  We had one factor,
right?  We had one factor we could
use: the Dow Jones price, right?
divided by the spot price, which would be
the SPX, which would be this, right?  It's
currently at
68.42, right?  Let's say the price of the
Dow Jones, uh, 5000, right?  So,
5000 divided by 6843,
that gives us a factor of 6 point
something, right?  6 point something, 7 point something.
We set that value here.
So, on that day we
had it at 6.95,
right?  At 6.95 we had it and this
gave us the correlation
with the price of the Dow Jones.  Remember
that this is for the SPX option.
Ready?  You believe we
can use the multiplier to
correlate the levels of the
SPX with the Dow Jones.
Understood?  Around there.
Perfect.
Let's reset this again.
We store it
here.
Ah, okay.
Okay, let's see what's going on here.  Let's go
here,
let's go to what is the
negative gamma located at this point,
right?
Remember that this negative gamma is
correlated with another level;
here we have negative gamma
correlated
with
negative delta.   It's
also good for us to review the
different profiles, uh,
for what purpose, for correlation.
Ready.
The different profiles for a
correlation are therefore relatively
important.  We also have the 68.40
profile here negative, also the delta
which is also
incorporated here in the range of the
negative range, right?  We see that these two
positive levels have been
swapping,
right?  between this and this we are
exchanging.
What we can also visualize is
that if we load history here,
you can also visualize it
.
Well, I'll be keeping an eye on
the comments on YouTube and
Discord
in case you have any questions.   Let's
see.
If it finishes loading.
Well, the platform is a little slow
because I'm doing
the broadcast.  I have Bootmap data,
and I'm streaming on Discord;
I'm also doing two streams
at the same time.  Uh, I
can see what happened from here, right?  Let's say,
in our upward movement
within the range.
Note that he, the net GES,
indicated that it was totally positive.  And
what I tell you is, if the Net Income is
positive, look for points of support in the
different profiles,
uh, such as, let's say,
the range.
Notice when we started with positive results here, we
saw that
the net gel was totally positive,
right?  The fulcrum
reflected to us
that it would be
this range that appeared here, this
small range.  If you can
see yourselves here.
Let's go back and forth.
This negative range, right?
This negative range
turned into a positive one and worked for us
as a small support.
Fom moving that negative range, that
positive range here.  They saw it
and started to fill it in, to add a
little more volume to that range.
About that range.  TRUE?
There we see.  That was, let's say, the one that
incorporated, let's say, the
upward movement of, ah, well, if we work
below that range, that
positive range, which we have here, let's say,
three little scales of the positive range,
right?  Which is, let's say, uh, and
we clearly also see
that this staircase sequence is
from highest to lowest, right?
Well, the volume traction isn't going to
be that big,
implying that this little
ladder is much wider.  It's
like a jump, it's like from here to here, it's
a small but quite large jump in volume
and liquidity is also incorporated
, right?
We can consider it as that type
of support.  So that
small range was also what gave us
a foothold to
continue the system.
We see here.  And look, I also really
like seeing that.
Clearly, then, it's a matter of
you visualizing it in each
of your tools as well.  I know it's a
little, let's say, tedious when we
look at all these kinds of graphs and say,
well, where do I start, right?  to
visualize the different
profiles, but I will
explain to them little by little how they can
incorporate it into any
trading method.
In any trading method.  Ready.
Notice when he says "I really like this".   I
also want
you to visualize that.
When it starts, let's say, to... uh...
when it starts to surpass a level,
right?  Like this
negative, this is the first gamma
negative, right?  And this is the second
negative range, referring, let's say,
to the profile, right?  We see that
below, then, or above, there is nothing
more to be found.  We have the first one and
this would be the second one.
And if you look closely,
at the moment of the
bullish continuation, did
you see?  Did you see the increase in volume?
How is it enlarged?  Notice
that small increase in volume, this
small increase in volume, right?
I added that this negative range was
positioned as the first and here in the other one they took away
, they auctioned off that volume
and clearly this point of 68.40
works for me with a small support, that
is, it is most likely that it should
work as support.  Look, there it is.
Let's see.   Did
you see?   It
works for me now as an opponent
clearly because it's
indicating to me, ah, look, at this moment I am
located right there, well, there I am,
yes, here I am right within this
negative range
that was what propelled me.  Well, another
thing to keep in mind is that
you can also adopt
a strategy that takes advantage of the fact that
the price moves in your favor, right?
As we see here
in the price advance in favor of a
trend and below this will happen
many times, we have seen this
too many times that the entry of
volume is below as
driving the price.  The same thing happens
when they put, let's say, a level of
liquidity in Boom, a
fairly large limit order that can boost the
price.
What do I mean?  I'm going to show you over here
.   This way
.
Yes, I think I am showing it.  Okay,
here I am showing.
Ready.  Let's see.
Let's see if we can find an
example here.
Okay
, here it is
at this point.   The
same thing that we saw there in
Gesbos also happens right here in
Bomma, the entry
of a point of limited order that is
found, let's say, in the book,
right?  We see that in the book it is
among the ASKs.  Here it is, you know that
above the price is an order,
above the price is a bit order, that
is, a limit order to buy on the
bit side, a limit order to sell
above the price which is ads,
right?
Uh, this is a limit sell order,
right?  What drives me when, look,
look, when it surpasses, right?  When
there's a trend, let's say, when there's
a break here from the zero range,
right?  Notice how this limit order is entered
, right?  To finish pushing the
price down, it's like saying, look,
I make the breakout and
these small investors
may have taken profit a little
lower because they are practically
pushing the price down, like
this very order 194. Look, it's
pushing the price down.  We can
visualize the same thing in the
GP tool,
the GP web tool.
Notice the volume inflow.  Did you
see it?
This small influx of volume
gives me a sense of continued upward momentum.   It
gives me the upward continuity.
Let's see where it is located at
this moment.
Look, notice how a small support worked for us at this moment
,
right?  the negative gamma and let's see
if we can visualize it
here
because explained
here it's not visible here,
we'll only visualize it
here in our tool.   It's there
, huh
?  Let's see, let's see, let's see, because it's already
loading.
Continue there.
There it is, there is still
continuity.
questions.  Hey, I'm listening here on
both Discord and YouTube
to find out the NQ price in the
multiplier, what's it like?
Hey, remember that there's already a
multiplier applied.  There is already a
multiplier applied for the ndx.
Ready?   You
can also multiply it
as we indicated.  Okay,
now I'm also going to add a
comment here
about what
the factor would be to do the division.   Wait a
minute, please, just a
moment, I'm
looking for something.
Okay, I'll
post them here on YouTube.
And here
this is the factor
that we take into account
and it is the one that we are going to put in the
multiplier.
Ready.
Wait, I'll finish, I'll finish
the live stream in
about 15 minutes.
Approximately 15 minutes
for any questions
you may have; you can answer them here.  I'm going to
explain why it's happening to me here
in each of the
profiles.   He
also wants us to see
the others, right?
Here we also have the NETs profile
of the range.
We can also exchange, and
change things up in each one of them.
This is the Delta's NES.
Let's do a historical analysis to
see what happened in Delta at these points
prior to all these
bullish continuation points.
or see if we can find some other
correlation that allows us to, say,
understand the price increase.
Let's dry it for a moment,
see if it charges.
While it's loading, I think I'll put the
bootmap while it
finishes loading
so you can also view it
with our tool.  Ready.
We are located here in Conical form.  Ah,
well, here we also see that
we have the negative delta, the
negative gamma, right?
Here, let's say, it worked for us as a
small support and a way to rejoin the
trend.
We're getting a little closer.
Perfect.
while this one from the web loads.
Well, here I am again.  And let's see, I'll
tell you about it here too.
Remember that we have
different packages, we have a new
package, we also have a new
package incorporated into
our tool.  Let's
visualize it.
Let's take a look at it on the
web for a moment.
Okay, we'll keep you updated
.  Uh, we have
our three packages that we
already had, right?  The Classy, ​​the
state, the order flow.  Uh,
a new tool element was incorporated,
especially for developers,
for those who also want to analyze
historical topics, do machine
learning, it can be machine learning, uh,
apply a little bit of
artificial intelligence.
Uh,
so that package is the quad one,
right?  This package includes all the
other three, right?  Class and state
order flow, but this allows us to bring
the history through the API for
development
starting from 90 days.
So that, and we also have a
multiticker web socket
where we can monitor
what's happening in each ticker.
When I talk about ticker, well, spx, the n,
the nxpy,
right?
etc.
Um, by monitoring, let's say,
key levels like the maximum delta, the
maximum gamma, uh, all that monitoring,
well, we can bring it down,
right?, to our team and we
can do match landing, well, with
that different,
uh, with that different data, right?
All the data, all the
class order flow data, we will be able to
download
into our,
let's say, our development.  They can
do a Python development
in 90 days, right?
and to say, well, which levels are
relatively important and which ones
react, let's say, on a weekly level, on a
daily level.  Um, for example, I would make, let's say
, an
algorithm that allows me to see if the zero
gamma will work for me as support or
resistance,
right?   I
can do that, I can download
that data, right?  And I can create a
learning module that allows me to see
if, during the course of the day, that
zero range will work as support
or resistance.   That's what
this package is for, right?
Ready.  Now that that's explained, let's get to the flow.
Uh, totally positive.  We are in a
positive place for Netoges.  Remember
what I often tell you, that
Netoges
manages the main trend that will
occur during the day.  So, despite
the
spot price, well, the price
can make it a low, right?
But the net guest is the one in charge and is the one
who will give me the
complete address to the system.  I can,
let's say, create a strategy with package
four, for example, that if net is
positive, right?
between a purchase between a
market purchase at the start of the market, at the
start of the market and the purchase comes out at the
end of the day.
Let's look at what happened yesterday so you can
also visualize what
we talked about
yesterday.  Let's see, let's see, let's see.   I'm going
to remove this.
Let's just leave the net get,
but let's put it
here.
Well, also look at what I was telling you
So, even though the net gets here is
showing me
the net gets started to be negative,
but after about half an
hour all the incorporation was
positive, right?
When the incorporation is totally
positive,
look, notice that it will always
continue to be positive, positive, positive,
positive.  In other words, the first hour, the
first hour of the net get is super
important because it will
practically guide me in the
price trend during
the day.  What did we do
here?  That's right, totally
bullish.  Here, practically at
the end of the session, it no longer
has a bearish point, but is
simply a pullback, right?  All
this upward movement that we already saw,
all this movement that happened in
the first hour or half hour, right?
The net already shows me the entire trend.
Let's look at other days too.  Remember that
I can see historical data here,
and I can see historical data
in all of our
packages.   I
can load
from the 28th,
Friday the 28th.
Uh, here too exactly the same,
totally positive.  Totally
positive, right?  which indicate to me,
let's say, the whole trend, the whole
trend of the day for the 26th,
the 27th was a holiday.   They're
also indicating a positive result here,
right?  Positive, positive.  The first
hour is super important,
base.  Let's say the net result is
positive; that will indicate the entire
trend.
Let's move on to the other one.
It's totally positive, right?
here also
positive.  Well, it's much
clearer, isn't it?  These points
are also much clearer.
Hey, remember that when we have
resistance points here, right?  Regarding
support, that's a point like support,
zero line support, zero line support
, zero line support,
zero line support, zero line support, which we
had already discussed
in the tog can work for me as
support.
At what point?  Well, not here, here
we have a data loss, but look
here, notice how close it is to the support
of the day of the zero of the net guess,
right?  It works for me as a support tool.  And here we
have, look, we have a
larger range of puts than gets, right?  It's going to be
continuation
26.
Here I'm going back again
so you can also visualize
those points.   Around here,
almost support for the day of the
net zero gets me, it works as
support.
We see that the increased
participation has been positive
all week, right?
A negative space is not incorporated, let's say,
in net.  Let's say calculations like that for
our quad package are relatively
important so you can consider
when an expansion of the net
gets me can influence the price to
continue totally bullish. Let's see
what the NDX is.  Well, we also
found it
a little more disorganized.
Look, here when it makes the break,
notice also that when it makes the
break of the one
we also visualized today, when it makes the
break of the
zero point of the net gets,
right?   It is
also relatively important.
Uh, we sent what is the
state packet.  Okay,
we're joining in at a
bearish point.
Okay, we'll
finish this session
in a few minutes.  Any
questions you have can be left in the
comments section regarding our
packages.   They're asking
here, they're asking
here, they're asking on Discord, how do I get the
net gets thing to work?
Okay, you enter the flow packager.  I'm going
to answer that question.  I'm sorry to hear that
.
Uh, you're joining our
Orderflow package, right?
And you're heading this way in terms of metrics, right?
And here you select net getets.
Today we are talking about
Netogets.  We will be incorporating
the other metrics in the following
days.
Ready?
There we are.   They're
also asking on Discord, "Are
you going to extend the 90 years of
historical data?"  At the moment I don't think it's
planned.  Uh,
we'll continue with these filters.   There are some
new things coming
next year.  Remember to purchase
each of the packages so that you
are aware of
or subscribe to a
package to receive
news of
our updates.
Uh,
well, I'm going for a moment.   They
should also visualize an
integration.
M, here I am.  Perfect.
Hey, what's going on here again?   I'm going, I'm going
.  I reiterate to you
again the breaking of the cer
gamma, right?  The forceful breaking
of the gamma cer gives me an explosion.  It might be
a bearish explosion.  Notice that
at this moment being gamma now
works as a resistance for me, right?
For continuity,
right?  Here we saw that the expansion
was much greater than what we saw
previously
here.  Let's see, this way
, right?  This small
expansion was very short and at this
point we have seen that we had this
range that was working for me
as support.
Ah, well, that's good to keep
in mind too.
Uh, they
always have to be, let's say, the two
opposite sides.
Uh, you always have to see both
opposite sides.  What do I mean?  I'm
coming in here.  I started here
at zero range, right?  Here's the thing: that
's totally theoretical.  They need to
mix it with other points of analysis
that I will also be explaining.
When we analyze here, let's say, with this
ceramic, let's say, here I could have come
in and picked up some
tips, right?, for profit.  Here are
some tips for making a profit.  Here
at the breakout, here are some
profit tips too.  If they want to unite a
little more, they have to mix it with
the other profiles.
Remember that down here we've
seen that the bullish addition was
due to a range that also
started to grow, right?, which was this one
here.
Uh, they need to visualize very well whether there is
sufficient liquidity
below as well.  There are many things
you have to take into account,
let's say, in the different tools they
use.  If there is liquidity below
to make the bearish continuation,
we see that there was still liquidity here,
things that one also realizes as
one goes, as let's say,
learning, learning from the market, there is
still liquid to be made to
consume, right?  which brought me back to the upside
.  Uh,
exactly the
same thing happens here too.
Here you also have to visualize that
at the moment of the breakout, right?,
it breaks the range levels in order to
make a bearish continuation.   For
example, those are different examples.   Let's
see,
ask here.
Okay, I think I'll leave it for
another 5 minutes.  I think I started a
little late, but I'll start for
another 5 minutes so we can get on with
other tasks.
Um,
how do you interpret delta in
combination with gets?  Delta
works, positive delta
works excellently
for incorporating long positions
, negative delta,
uh, for short positions.
We saw that our delta,
if we quoted ourselves, if we chose
the book a little more, right?
We see that we are in a negative delta,
right?
A negative delta can work
for short positions.
Uh, this negative delta,
let's say, let's see, this way, this way, this way
, this way.  I want to open
the book a little more.  Okay, I can't see the
history here, but I'd like to see it.
This negative delta, notice that in this
positive delta the price will react
.  Did you see it?
This delta, this positive delta, here at
this point the price reacts to me.  The
same applies to the negative delta.  If the
negative delta is above,
right?  Uh, let's say, let's say here at
this point, right?   The
negative delta will work as a
resistor for me.
We actually have a negative delta
located right near
the center where the price is found
.  In other words, this negative delta
might work as support,
but it's much better if it works as
resistance.  If it is broken, let's say, from
below, if it is a break from
below.
Ready.
Uh, what can they do?  The
combination of the GU
with the delta can also be
combined.  Do you
remember that we saw that we
had a correlation between gamma and
delta?
Ah, I think I'm transmitting
anymore, I don't know.  Yes. Done.  Do you remember that we
've seen correlations before?
This is a positive range, right?  It has this
small negative delta, right?  But if
this negative delta is located here, it is
a greater correlation that the price will
bounce off that point.
Remember that the correlation between
different profiles, between two profiles,
is much better.
Hey, hi Juan.  Okay, ask around
here.   but it's
only useful for rhythmic.  Right now
we're in talks with
Bootmap to launch this
product,
this product that's super
innovative, right?  In my
opinion, it's something very innovative
within Bootmap
because there isn't anything like it.  There isn't one.  Hey, it
works for now with rhythmic data.   I do
n't know if it's working with
data from.
I think so, we're already using
Bootmat data, we should be, we have
n't had any more complaints about it
within our channel, so it
should already be working with
data from boommap.
Well, we see that the breakup is already happening here
, right?  From the zero-range model to the
explosion of pure sales, right?  I
can use the range as a
support, as a resistance.  There it is.
That's where a lot of purchases come in.  Notice
that the gamma cer is
hitting me right there.
Ah, I can take it here.  Let's have a
sale.  Remember that this is not
investment advice, this
is a
demo account, or don't take it because
some people do, right?
No, no investment advice.  Hey,
there it is.  Look,
notice how many, many
purchases are coming in again, they're on top,
right?
Okay, so if I put a buy point here
, I position my stop different from
that breakout and
bullish continuation due to the net get, right?
and my this just below the zero
range.  Remember that these days I've
only been logging in through the zero-
gama channel to explain how the
zero-gama thing works.  Ready?
You have seen that I have explained in
these days everything that zero gamma is
so that you can visualize how it
works
with that zero gamma.  Look at the
300 volume break above the 0 range.
I went in when I saw, when I started to
see that they began to point from below,
the zero-gamut started to appear
below, not above, right?
To make the bullish continuation,
right?
Hey, what else do we see around here?  Okay,
let's get to
this, it seems to have gotten stuck.
Mm.  There it is.
Oh, we have a positive delta.
Ah, but on the Nets' side, on the
NES side, we had a positive delta.
Ah, well, here in Bootmap, Bootmap doesn't
show us
this.  We need to configure it
in the settings of
our profile indicators for
each of the
integration profiles.
I'm
showing
the profiles here, right?  These are the profiles
for the current day, that is, for DT zero.
Ready?
Okay,
so, sure, let's see, uh, these
profiles are from 0 DT, they're not from 1
T. Here we're going to move over
here.  Let's switch to the
tool here on the web, right?
Here I can swap between 0 of
t and 1 of t, right?  We bring up
LaTeX, well, LaTeX and Net as the
biggest example, right?
Let's recharge for a moment
here.  Ask on YouTube, huh
?  It's a shame that nothing can be seen here on Discord
, nothing can be seen at all.  Uh,
when nothing is visible it's because I'm on
the Bootmap side.  Ready.  Hey, you can
also go to the YouTube live stream and
help us out by giving it a like.
Oh, thank you very much.  Uh,
look at this delta, this negative delta,
this positive delta, the NETs side,
right?
Uh, since it's a positive delta, remember
that I just confirmed that
when deltas are in favor
of the trend, in this case positive, they
can
push the price much further, right?
like that positive delta we just saw here
.
Well, on this side we have negative delta,
which is negative delta now and is
functioning as a resistance.  This
little negative delta here and there,
right?  It is the last negative delta.
Look,
it's almost the last negative delta.
It works like a resistor, right?   They
also
have to mix it
with other indicators, right?
What is the YouTube link?  I'll
send them to you now.
Okay, let's share this here.
And that's it, all done
.  I think we can call
today's session over here.  I hope you liked it.  Uh,
I think we've already added quite a few
topics
to the broadcast,
uh,
and we're already an hour and 15 minutes in. Done.
I lengthened it a little bit more so you can
visualize our tool a little more
.
Okay, let's go over here one last time so you can
see what the bootmap is,
which was, let's say, our entry point
for the purchase here.  Same
entrance that you could have
located, remember?  Just
two more minutes and I'll cut the
same outfit.  We were also able to
relocate the purchase entrance here
after the co-range, right?  And I could have
easily taken all this continuity with me.  For example, right
?  This is a take, that's totally an
example take.  Well, I'm
cutting the transmission off here.  I hope you
enjoyed today.  See you
tomorrow.  again for a
broadcast.